ونواصل من الخبر المتفاعل حيث اعلنت
الشرطه البريطانيه انها عثرت على ثلاثه
قتله وثلاثه جرحى في حوادث منفصله بمدينه
نوتنهام بواسطه انجلترا والقت القبض على
شخص مشتبه به في الحوادث واوضحت الشرطه
انها اعتقلت رجلا في الحاديه والثلاثين من
عمره بشبهه محاوله القتل بعد العثور على
ثلاثه قتلى في المدينه بينما تم نقل الجرح
الثلاثه الى المستشفى وكانت الشرطه قد
اعلنت صباح اليوم انها تتعامل مع حادث
خطير وسط المدينه مع استدعاء سيارات
الاسعاف والاطفاء الى المكان في حين حثت
هيئه النقل العام السكان على ايجاد طرق
بديله للتنقل في انتظار الانتهاء من
التحقيقات
في اول تعليق له على حادث نوتنجهام وصف
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك هذا
الحادثه بالصادم وقال انه على اطلاع دائم
على تطورات الوضع وانه يجب اعطاء الشرطه
الوقت الكافي للقيام بعملها
نوهتناك في تغريده له بسرعه استجابه
الشرطه وخدمات الطوارئ لهذا الحادث الذي
وقع صباح اليوم
مراسلتنا من لندن معنا الان مينا ما
الجديد
نعم الجديد حسب التقارير التي يعني قراتها
حتى الساعه تشير الى ان الشرطه المحليه
وليست شرطه مكافحه الارهاب هي التي تتعامل
مع هذه العمليه التي وصفتها شرطه بانها
حادث خطير وقع في وسط المدينه يعني ذلك
بان هذه العمليه حسب الشرطه البريطانيه
يعني بعد هذه التحقيقات التي لا تزال
مستمره حسب الشرطه البريطانيه الشرطه التي
اعلنت بان اعتقلت شخصا في الحاد و30 من
العمر
وقالت بعد العثور على ثلاثه
اشخاص قتلى اضافه الى الابلاغ عن عمليه
محاوله دهس من قبل سياره من نوع فان ونقل
ثلاثه اشخاص الى المستشفى هم الان لا
يزالون يتلق العلاج اذا ما دامت الشرطه
البريطانيه
المحليه في مدينه نوسنغان هي التي تتعامل
مع هذا الحادث هذا الحادث والذي الذي تقوم
خلال تحقيق فيه بجمع الادله الكافيه من
خلال يعني ايضا
جمع كاميرات المراقبه الصور التي سجلت سجل
سقطتها كاميرات المراقبه لا سيما من
المنازل المحليه والاماكن المحليه
الاماكن القريبه من هذه الحوادث الثلاث
التي تم الابلاغ عنها في الساعات المبكره
لهذا الصباح الشرطه قالت بان بعض الطرق
ستظل مغلقه قالت ايضا بان على الناس ان
يصبروا حتى الانتهاء من هذه التحقيقات
التي لا تزال في بداياتها الاوليه هناك
ايضا ردود من قبل السياسيين
متحدث باسم داونيو مكتب رئيس وزراء
البريطاني قال بان الرئيس وزراء ريشيسونا
يتم اطلاعه على مجريات التحقيقات التي لا
تزال جاريه في الوسط المدينه بشان هذه
الحوادث
الثلاث التي تعتقد الشرطه بانها مرتبطه
ببعضها البعض ريشيسون كما ذكرتم في تغريده
قال بانه يجب اعطاء الشرطه الوقت من اجل
اكمال هذه التحقيقات
وتمنا على عمل الشرطه المحليه شرطه وايضا
خدمات الطوارئ التي عجلت الى عين المكان
والتي لا تزال في عين المكان لتقديم
المساعده هناك ايضا
شرطه الشرطه الجنائيه التي لا تزال نسبت
خيام صغيره في المناطق الثلاث وقع فيها
وقعت في هذه الاحداث الحوادث الثلاث
التي تعتقد الشرطه بانها مرتبطه من اجل
جمع الادله لمعرفه الوقوف على ما حدث
تحديدا والدوافع التي ادت الى هذه الحوادث
وعمليه القتل ومحاوله عمليه محاوله الدهس
النواب الثلاثه من العماليين من حزب
العمال المعارض الثرو بيانا اعربوا فيه عن
صدمتهم لما جرى في مدينه وصفها بالجميله
هناك ايضا ردود افعال من السكان المحليين
كما ذكرت سابقا احد هؤلاء السكان الذي قال
بان الشرطه دقت بابا والساعه الخامسه ونصف
صباحا
لطلبت منه الحصول او مدها بما صورته كامره
المراقبه في منزله يبدو انه شخص يسكن جنب
احدى العمليات التي وقعت
الصباح الطوق الامني الواسع الذي ضربته
الشرطه البريطانيه حول وسط المدينه وتعليق
خدمه النقل العام بما في ذلك تعليق خدمه
شبكه
التروم واي وسط المدينه اثار نوع من القلق
لدى بعض سكان المدينه الذين تحدثوا عن
صدمتهم لما جرى بعضهم تحدث عن عن موجه من
العنف التي تزايدت في المدينه في الاشهر
الاخيره وبعضهم ايضا
اعرب عن صدمته لان هذه المدينه مريم تعتبر
مدينه هادئه ولا تعرف عليها اي تعرف باي
مناطق ممكن ان تكون حساسه حكوميه او غير
حكوميه من جهه اخرى بعض المحللين لا سيما
من عناصر الشرطه السابقين يعتقدون بان لدى
الشرطه الشرطه المحليه مهمه كبيره بين
يديها في هذه الاولى من هذه العوامل من
التحقيقات لا سيما ما يتعلق بجمع
المعلومات من يعني مداهمه بيت منزل هذا
الشخص المعتقل وايضا تمشيط وسائل التواصل
فحص وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي تخص هذا
الشخص لمعرفه ما اذا كان لدي على اي روابط
اخرى وطالما ان هناك طوق امني حسب هؤلاء
الخبراء الامنيين فان الشرطه فان الامور
تحت السيطره حسب تعبير احدهم شكرا جزيلا
لك من حربلو مراسله من لندن